former Pittsburgh Steeler ESPN NFL
analyst analyst Ryan Clark kind enough
to call it the program how are you Ryan
doing well rich how are you I'm doing
fine what do you make of everything
going on with honor man let me get this
right I have it written down mr. big
chest what do you make of mr. Podesta
kind of it's it's it's kind of strange
that this thing is just played out so
long and that it's been such a lengthy
soap opera from a team we are used to
seeing these things from you know you
start this season with levy on bill and
now ended with Antonio Brown it's really
been a strange season in western
Pennsylvania so you know it you
mentioned AV I don't know who's doing a
better job of fellas I mean a worse job
of selling themselves the teams right
now a B or a D Anthony Davis here in New
Orleans and so for me to kind of see
that Antonio is trying to force the hand
of the Pittsburgh Steelers he's not
speaking about Ben he's speaking about
Mike Tomlin just doing some things that
I don't necessarily think help his trade
value but it may be forcing an
organization who doesn't want to be
involved in this type of drama to make a
move that he wants them to make wise you
know Ryan though there's so many coaches
out there in front offices that think
you know he may have done X Y & Z that
is problematic or dramatic or too public
in his previous spot but I'll change him
I can fix him the thing that that I
heard out of his Instagram live that
that really gave me pause is him
mentioning guaranteed dollars for the
first time that you're now you wouldn't
just be inviting everything you that
becomes with Antonio Brown into your
house he's got three years left on a
contract there's no question that
there'd be some sort of contractual
stance that might be adverse to the team
or the front office right around the
corner if not upon acquisition Ron when
you agree it's a very difficult
situation you know when you look at the
way that contracts are structured in the
NFL and the way that those things play
against the cap that's something that
you really have to dig into before even
trying to acquire Antonio Brown and then
you look at all the mess and all the
things that have gone along with him
and the way that this saga has played
out is that something that you want to
invite into your locker room right is
that something that you want to think
the chemistry of what you have going on
and so they're gonna be a lot of things
that go into acquiring Antonio Brown
that don't just include his play on the
field we know that he's one of the
greats at the position right now he's
the guy that's produced over the last
six years like we've never seen in
history but that is telling off he is
there is a three in front of his age and
I mean you have those things you have to
start considering some different things
other than what you put all fill in the
last six years where did you go from the
future how does it affect our locker
room also how does it affect our ability
to acquire other talent around you and
if you have to if you get a Tony around
you have to believe that you're one wide
receiver away from what in the Super
Bowl but remember he was with Big Ben
Roethlisberger levy on Bill and those
guys never had that opportunity alright
Ryan Clark here on the Rich Eisen show
let's get into some of these things
involving your former teammates here
when Antonio Brown said that Big Ben has
an owners like mentality in terms of
criticizing his teammates
is that accurate do you think in extent
I don't necessarily think that all
owners are that public and that public
in the way that they address their team
the way that they talk about their
players obviously we see someone like
Jerry Jones who's extremely involved in
that maybe John Elway we've had some
different things happen if you bring
those guys to the podium to speak about
coaching changes but owners don't really
get involved in that I think it's
something we haven't necessarily seen
from franchise quarterbacks when you
look at guys around the league there's
usually a put it on meat mentality and
then has most certainly been very open
with what he feels about teammates
whether that's positive or negative and
I think those things don't always play
out well in the locker room when you're
looking at a guy in the leadership
position so that's my I guess let me
let's then really put it out on the
table here Ryan Clark so let's say
Antonio Brown gets his wish and it sure
looks
he will he's gone how many people do you
think in that locker room will look at
Ben and say this is Party Party your
fingerprints are on this thing and then
that would be a lettering issue for
Tomlin I don't necessarily know if it'll
be a lingering issue but I do know that
that is the sentiment to some degree and
not just in the Antonio Brown situation
I think in many of the different issues
they've had in the locker room
um his leadership style his natural
leadership ability is something that Ben
has been trying to work on I can tell
you as a teammate of his it wasn't
something that came natural to him he
wasn't one of those guys who walked in
right away and he said you know what
this is the face of our franchise and he
knows how to handle it and so I think
he's had some missteps along the way in
this Antonio Brown situation and in
other situations with the teams you go
back to Mason Rudolph being drafted and
some things that are staying there so he
will shoulder some of this blame but I
also know they've been dealing with
Antonio Brown situation levy on bail
situation all year and the team still
tried to go out and play but this is
something that's been looming over them
I think they'll feel good to get some of
those things out of the way and I also
believe they know Ben well enough to
continue to go out and play just
understanding who he is right
Bryan Clark here in the Rich Eisen show
and then of course the the idea
certainly from fans in Pittsburgh who
adored juju Smith Schuster feel that he
could just step in and be that guy and
have those Antonio Brown numbers where
do you stand on that subject Ryan do you
think a lot of juju Smith's numbers have
to do with the fact that there is an
all-time great that's been on the other
side of the field attracting attention
absolutely 100% you get an opportunity
to be matched up on number two corner
backs even when you don't face the
number two quarterback you have a
cornerback you have an opportunity to
not be double the team which gives you a
chance to excel which dudu had I won't
tell you this rich when when juju was
drafted I talked to coach Teague and he
told me they actually brought in Hinds
and training camps one of the years he's
been there but they actually told me we
believe he's Hines Ward but mortality
and when you look at the Pittsburgh
Steelers
dreamily hydrate Heinz is a Pro Bowl
caliber wide receiver ball so one of the
toughest individuals in our locker room
and that's how they feel about juju they
love this fun love experience but also
the way that he competes the way that he
fights the way that he takes losses on
the chin and accepts his accountability
they love all those things about him but
we have to understand when Antonio Brown
is the wider receiver op you opposite of
you you get opportunities to be faced
with matchups that are favorable for you
and you also have a future hall-of-fame
quarterback I'm not saying that
juju Smith Schuster doesn't put up large
numbers but to just assume that he can
be Antonio Brown like for over the
extended period of time that Antonio has
been I think that's a little
presumptuous being that nobody else was
that effective in that type of period of
time either a few more minutes left with
Ryan Clark of ESPN former Steeler here
on the Rich Eisen show so let's get
let's just really put it put it it put a
fine point on this year Ryan here we are
with Antonio Brown announcing even
though it's really not his announcement
but it seems like it's going to happen
his exit from Pittsburgh Le'Veon Bell
about to be a free agent we assume going
somewhere else and the big ben Brown
Le'Veon Bell era will end with zero
Super Bowls and everyone wondering if
Big Ben is part of the cause and is the
coach part of the cause and how did we
get here to this point do you think I
think I think everybody's part of it I
don't think anyone gets to be absolved
of their responsibility in this
situation whether it's coach Tomlin
making the correct decisions and the
correct Corrections when it comes to
Tonio Brown some of his antics Big Ben
and some of the things that he's done
not you know you go to Kevin Cole burden
you know Art Rooney jr. and how they've
handled the levy on ville contract
situation I think everybody has a hand
in what's happened with this team you
know what I also think the rich I think
we're in the error to where the New
England Patriots has confused us right
they have made us think that consistent
excellence is easy to attain and it's
not we watched them go nine of 18 years
and research
get that until they won six Super Bowls
the Pittsburgh Steelers who have been in
business for over 80 years with the team
that had the most Super Bowls and they
only had six it's hard to win it's hard
to get to a Super Bowl and so I think we
we are very hard on the Pittsburgh
Steelers because of the history of
excellence what the organization has
represented and because they play with
the New England Patriots who have made
us think that you're supposed to get
there when you have talent some of the
discord we've seen there has not allowed
this team that reaches full potential
but I think everybody played a part in
that and you can't just blame it on
those three guys coach Tomlin Ben
Roethlisberger and Antonio Brown as
bitching all right last one for you Ryan
Clark knowing what you know and and
knowing you know you and then also
knowing colleagues of mine at the NFL
Network who have played there are things
that you can't say on the air that you
know so knowing what you know on
everything having been a teammate and
played and all of that business would
you acquire Antonio Brown right now
would you take him on your team in the
right situation oh what's that
and the right situation with the with
the right head coach with somebody who
understands fully what you're getting
right that there's a the conversation
that mr. Rooney and Antonio Brown had is
a conversation that needs to be had
before you ever acquire when you're
speaking about your quarterback what are
your plans on all set how will you coach
him how will he be treated and I think
the hard part about that is what team
wants to go through all that that thinks
Antonio Brown is worth it and I believe
that that's going to be difficult you
look at a team like the San Francisco
49ers who I know have been rumored to be
one of the teams that Tony around would
like to play with can coach Shanahan
keep him under wraps his Jimmy Garoppolo
at quarterback but enough for him to
feel like he has an opportunity to excel
in a game that he doesn't get four to
five catches or five or more targets how
do you treat him how do you deal with it
and so when you look at a situation like
that it seems really hard plus all the
things we talked about already rich it
seems really hard that there's a perfect
spot for Antonio Brown see what Mike
I follow up to that and again this is
the last one Ryan for you is that no no
but wouldn't Mike Talman know who
Antonio Brown was what you're getting
into you say like he's got to be a coach
that knows what you're getting with him
Mike Tomlin won a Super Bowl I mean Mike
Tomlin it didn't just fall off the
turnip truck right I mean you know as
you refer to him as coach T so if he
can't figure it out how could somebody
else you know what do better I would say
I would say I would say it was one of
those things that you feel like if you
give people independence if you allow
guys to be their own personality if you
allow guys to be adults who are good
player players who are who are very who
are very into their craft you feel like
they give you the love back I'll let you
be free I've let you I've let you grow
into who you are so you feel like
they'll have some accountability to you
you feel like they would look out for
you in some way
and that's not what's happened with that
Tony or Tony who has grown to a point to
where it's more about him then than it
is team and I think that was something
for me I always saw right like that was
a part of him I always saw when you
draft a guy in the sixth round when you
know the hardships he's dealt with
throughout life you know the way that
the ways that he had had to take care of
himself you think that those things were
showing loyalty and just an Antonio
Brown it didn't it was a miscalculation
by a coach Teague and I think even more
so it was a miss in correction once
those things started to go sideways
which now has is at this point
Brian great stuff as always great job on
ESPN always enjoy our chats we'll chat
again soon thanks for calling you bet
that's Ryan Clark the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience